we're going to stop global warming that
was the resolve of last year's
international climate conference to
achieve that co2 emissions and fossil
fuel use have to be reduced oil gas and
coal have been reliable sources of
profit until now that is prices have
been plunging for quite some time and
investors are taking vast amounts of
their money out of the sector painful
pictures at the 2015 Paris climate
conference the world's nations agreed to
end the carbon based economy but
smokestacks are still spewing out
greenhouse gases for how much longer ten
years perhaps fifty model cities such as
Rijo in the Chinese province of Shang
Gong demonstrate that the transition to
solar and wind energy has begun there
are examples like these all around the
world despite that phasing out coal oil
and natural gas won't happen overnight
but hasn't the fossil fuel industry long
been playing for time
divest now for years a worldwide
movement has been urging people to stop
investing in fossil fuels people are
just lining up to try and get involved
its initiator Bill McKibben gives the
coal industry 15 more years at most
otherwise the climate expert tells large
crowds at events preventing global
temperatures from rising more than 2
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
levels cannot be achieved pleasure for
me to get to be here today is McKibben a
radical think we know what we need to do
I think we've peeled away the layers the
onion we've gotten to the very heart of
things as of tonight we're taking on the
fossil fuel industry directly the moment
has come that we have to make real
Spanish we're reaching women's the
biggest limit that we're running into
maybe that we're running out of
atmosphere into which to put the waste
products of our society particularly the
carbon dioxide that's the ubiquitous
byproduct of burning fossil fuel London
this is the source of the data McKibben
relies on carbon trackers and NGO has
determined that the enormous sums
invested in fossil fuel companies funds
and insurance policies are at risk the
main assets are the oil gas and coal in
the ground and the extent to which that
you know the future business of these
companies is based on those assets and
particularly if they start pouring
significant amounts of money into
developing those I mean for example
we've seen a recent example the shell
poured around eight billion dollars into
drilling in the Arctic and there's now
pulled out of the Arctic's of course
that eight billion is now lost you could
describe that as a value destruction
a carbon bubble is said to threaten
those funding shell and other fossil
fuel companies a disastrous devaluation
of their investments is looming what
Greenpeace activists have long been
claiming is now considered the
scientific consensus we can only allow
ourselves to use a fifth of the world's
reserves at the same time more and more
people understand that the fossil fuel
industry works by using everyone's
savings invested in funds and insurance
policies these companies are a rogue
force they're outlaws they're not out
was against the laws of the state they
get to write those for the most part but
there a law against the laws of physics
if they carry out their business plan
the planet tanks more than 500
institutions around the world have by
now pledged to divest more than three
point four trillion dollars from the
coal and oil sectors the rally was party
include cities such as Oslo institutions
like the Rockefeller Brothers fund and
ensures such as aliens it's great it is
putting pressure but we need also to
create a hard place to the vestments
Rock we need to map out the transition
for the fossil fuel industry around
which mainstream financial institutions
can engage our alarm bells also ringing
in the financial world the City of
London the bank of montreal's global
asset management is one of the world's
top funds managers the institution was
worried about its portfolios before the
Paris summit where might it find new
investment opportunities outside the
coal and gas industries as v60 remarked
assist us it's most important for the
markets to have this energy transition
take place with his few surprises as
possible that was one of our demands to
the g7 and g20 members on the part of
investors we actively promoted having
the two-degree target implemented in a
way that markets can adjust to advise it
on gazette Stewart just marked as East
off Einstein can
the transition from coal and oil won't
be enforced with a big bang but
gradually via limits on emissions the
Paris conference cop21 produced a
situation that big money can work with
femen's even formally drunk exits if we
sit down with fund managers and say we
can predict everything we can calculate
our carbon footprint and what it says
about investment risk that's the point
where things get going investment it
easy cool dusty victa card it has does
faded is his victims it's important that
the cop21 framework gives us political
guidelines so we as investors can say
okay we can move within these parameters
you can get some now we can decide where
to divest and where to invest invest Ian
yeah so that's our job to rewrite the
story for the divestment movement the
most recent climate conference was a
success but its opponents from the coal
and oil sector are also pleased with the
Paris agreement the big money will be
able to rely on its old sources of
profit for quite a while yet